man spritzt sich das einfach da rein da
muss ich das da oben drücken
[Musik]
und dann war es das auch schon
fertig ein kleiner Peaks und man nimmt
ab das verspreche dann zumindest
zahlreiche tiktoker inne wo Diabetes
Medikament zum Abnehmen es geht ja so
durchschnittlich immer ein Kilo in der
Woche runter der neue abnehmtrend ist
aber umstritten die eine findet Spritze
es super Methode zum Gewicht verliere
und die andere kritisieren das Lied wo
so abnehmet fulls und sich sowas abnetz
einfach machen
ich freue mich ich spritze ein sacker
für Menschen wo unter ihrem Gewicht
liefert oder befürchte Therapie ein
gefährlicher abnehmtrend of social media
aber bevor ich bekomme in letzter Zeit
im privaten Umfeld aber auf Social Media
immer wieder mit über wir lügt mit der
spritzewand abnehmen und das kriege ich
ehrlich gesagt
abnehmen und darum auf Medikament
zurückgegriffen
auf Social Media will mich erinnert das
einfach
die ganze abnehmtrend
irgendwelche shady Tipps gebe mir
schneller und besser kann abnehmen und
die ganze Detox Sachen
noch erinnern eine Feed gespielt hat ist
Jenny sie dokumentierte ihre Videos wie
viel sie mit dem Medikament pro Woche
abnimmt heute es spritzenwochen Nummer
zehn ich bin diese Woche immer noch auf
neuen Kilo und das aber auch wieder weil
ich Periode habe ich kontaktiere sie und
das bartag später ladet sie mich zu
ihrer high-i sie wohnt mit ihrer Familie
in der
Wohnung als Nageldesignerin
freut mich auch Jenny hat ihr das Leben
mit dem Gewicht des kämpfen kann sie hat
alles ausprobiert zum Abnehmen Jens
studiert
hat hat sie vor ihrem Arzt
tanzmedikament und sempic verschrieben
der Wirkstoff regulierte
Blutzuckerspiegel und macht dass man
schneller satt wird Konsequenz man nimmt
ab
weil die Nadel ist ja wirklich winzig
also die ist wirklich sehr sehr klein
Jenny muss ich Medikament oder eben
umgangssprachlich abnehmen
und ich halte es dann für 20 Sekunden
und dann ist das eigentlich auch schon
das gewesen nein
so dünn und kurz
und dann war es das auch schon na bewirt
Kriege von Medikament wir Übelkeit
Durchfall oder Erbrechen
für Ihre Community of tiktok haltet sie
ihre Fortschritt fest so hallo wir sind
in Woche 12 angelangt mit der
abnehmspritze ich bin jetzt diese Woche
immer noch bei
11 Kilo also ich wiege jetzt 83 es geht
ja so durchschnittlich immer ein Kilo in
der Woche runter
wobei ich sagen muss es ist auch also
eben wenn ich auch nur bei dem Gewicht
mal stehen bleiben würde also das ist ja
schon für mich eine totale Erleichterung
ich möchte auf gar keinen Fall wieder
130 Kilo werden und so mache ich das ich
halt euch auf dem laufenden
zum Teil hat sie zaduss
alles Sache wo man eigentlich ein
Fachpersonen und es schreibt ihre viel
Kritik entgangen da gibt's jetzt zum
Beispiel der das sagt jemand ja
ätzend ich verstehe nicht wie man sich
freiwillig Chemie in den Körper spritzt
ja absolut fahrlässig sowas zum Abnehmen
zu promoten echt krank
jetzt keine medizinische grundheizung
abnehmen aber solche Idee abnimmt
finde ich nicht weil das Medikament ist
und bleibt verschreibungspflichtig und
da habe ich ja nicht die Verantwortung
für ich meine ich kann den ja nicht das
Zeug liefern ich habe ja damit nichts zu
tun ich habe keinen Nutzen davon
ich wäre einfach selber persönlich
wirklich so froh gewesen hätte ich jetzt
sowas gesehen und hätte dann auch zum
Arzt gehen können und fragen können so
hey ich habe da was gehört darf ich das
vielleicht auch ausprobieren und wenn
jetzt das so ein junges Mädel kommt und
findet sie muss jetzt unbedingt zwei
Kilo abnehmen da wird ihr dass der Arzt
ja sowieso nicht verschreiben also das
die ganzen halt immer so stehen ja also
da wurde ich auch schon gefragt ob ich
irgendwie das Zeug den schicken könnte
und was weiß ich und ja ja ein Vorwurf
wo immer wieder kommt ist das Jenny
vogelseki und diszipliniert und einfach
zu viel es ging nichts Vorurteil
gegenüber hochgewichtige Adipositas kann
aber auch ganz andere gründet zum
Beispiel erbliche psychische Faktoren
Medikament oder Stoffwechselerkrankungen
das schreibt Uni Zürich auf ihrer
Webseite
von mir zu erwarten dass ich jetzt mein
Leben lang hungern muss und mein Leben
lang irgendwie vier fünf Mal die Woche
ins Fitnessstudio Rennen muss damit ich
normal aussehen ist dass das normale
also wenn man jetzt einen schlanken
Menschen fragt was macht der denn für
seine Figur und für seine Gesundheit
dann wird er sagen ja ich habe mal
angefangen mit Fitness ich gehe da ab
mein Herz war ich schon wieder ein
halbes Jahr nicht und wenn du ihn fragst
was ist das du eigentlich den ganzen Tag
dann wird dir auch 90% von den schlanken
sagen ja ich ist eigentlich was ich will
es mir eigentlich egal ich achte da
überhaupt nicht drauf ist kannst du
nicht das kenne ich nicht habe ich noch
nie gekannt also ich habe noch nie in
meinem Leben so leben können wie ich
jetzt gerade bin das ist wirklich also
ein Unterschied also eine Befreiung
wirklich das kann man gar nicht
beschreiben das habe ich noch nie
gekannt dass ich essen konnte was ich
will
körperlich Gott der Jenny gut aber Angst
davor immer wieder ich für sie sehr
belastend sie zahlt Kräfte für Spritze
und das sind 140 Franken pro Monat
übrigens selber
ich kann nachvollziehen wieso das Jenny
seitens die Spritze sich so befreit weil
du das Gespräch mit ihrer und auch durch
Gespräche der Vergangenheit wo ich mit
Lied
erfahre ich immer wieder wie heavy dass
der Drucker Gesellschaft ist zu müssen
in enorm inneren
schlank sie und dass der Trend durch
online Inhalt noch auf verstärkt werden
und darum finde ich sehr genau doch
kritisch dass Jenny ihre abnimmt journey
auf tik tok Tal natürlich genauso zahlt
man doch wieder aufs Konto von
abnehmtrend
ursprünglich ist Medikament für
Diabetiker in entwickelt wurde
unterdessen wird aufgeschrieben zum
Abnehmen Krankenkasse zahlt
Patientinnen in höhere BMI Hand und so
er Ernährungsberatung und die Eltern
stattgefunden hat und es wird erwartet
dass die Betroffene sich körperlich
betätigt wer es nimmt muss ich auch
darauf Medikament jahrelang oder sogar
lange
absetzt verpufft ad wirklich wieder und
Gewicht kann zurückkommen
was wiederum unzählige Posts und Artikel
zu dem Thema generiert in letzter Zeit
hüfen sich abbricht darüber dass dünn
sie wieder inseki und Heroin schick als
das abgemagerte Schönheitsideal aus der
90er ich treffe sie im Kanton Aargau
als ganz einfaches Mittel zum Abnehmen
ja reflektieren was einem da jetzt so
präsentiert wird auf so Plattformen
natürlich gibt es Dir wo ehrlich postet
und nachher geht es aber auch Leute
sagen so einfach mit dem abknoten
einfach kein Appetit mehr kann ich alles
auch schon gesehen
das finde ich dann wirklich
problematisch will das sind Realität ein
falsche Realität darstellt falsches Bild
darüber vermittelt was ist denn genau
ist und wie ist denn ganz genau ich will
es ist kein Zuckerschlecken elena hat
starke Begleiter von der spritzen kann
aber will sie auch mental unter ihrem
Gesicht
aufgenommen
regelmäßig übergehen und hat dann schon
zweiter Tag gemerkt das wird kein Spaß
das ist nicht lustig dass ich kein
magische Spritze und Puffer ich bin
jetzt zack
durchführen wie es mir geht wie viel ich
jedes mal recht Spritze
aufgeschrieben die erste sechs Wochen wo
sie Medikament know hat hat Elena
praktisch jeden Tag müsse Erbrechen und
hat unter Verstopfung und trotzdem sägt
das
Gesellschaft das muss sie auch sehr
schmaler sacken aber wenn du sagst
ja das hat absolut ein bisschen
wie weniger wird fangt
das denn jetzt überhaupt nicht und
ja es ist eigentlich mega schlimm wenn
ich jetzt so erzähle aber Menschen fast
schon enttäuscht das muss ich nicht so
oft übergeht wie auch schon und man
verliert sich der eigentliche Sinn von
Medikament wo er einfach so Lied Appetit
Unterdrückung ist bzw das künstlich
machte völlig Gefühl im Magen der Druck
müssen
[Musik]
eigentlich Gesundheit und ich meine das
fängt schon das hat im teenage Alter
angefangen mit dem Mobbing
keine Ahnung
natürlich auch von der Familie man wird
von Anfang an extrem verglichen immer
mit allem
Cousine oder die und dir sicher
internalisiert und ähm gar nicht anders
obwohl es Medikament beim ersten Mal so
schlimm in Nebenwirkungen
im Gegensatz zu der Elena macht Jenny
eigentlich nur mit positiven Erfahrungen
mit der Spritze aber das Abnehmen ist
ja mit ihr noch Hund immer drüber rettet
hi
Wie geht's
hallo
als Kosmetikerin und hat Hund inne womit
der Spritze abnehmen
also das ist genau das was ich
eigentlich schon immer mein Leben lang
wollte dass ich einfach normal leben
kann und essen kann was ich will einfach
in der normalen Menge oder es hat
eigentlich
im Fitnessstudio abkämpft hat zum
schlanker werden
eine Stunde lang auf diesem scheiß
depper da oder was das ist eine Stunde
lang habe ich mich da abgequält bei Puls
140 hat fast nichts mehr gegessen wenn
wirklich in die Magersucht schon fast
reingerutscht
und es war wirklich auch wie so eine
Sportsucht aber nur aus dem Grund weil
ich nachher ein schlechtes Gewissen
hatte wenn ich mal einen Tag nicht
gegangen bin braucht als langfristig
nicht fehlen es Gewicht ist ein gleich
wieder zurück sie ist letztes Jahr sogar
so vertieflich sie dass sie sich
überleitet ein magerballon in
Spritze ist viel weniger invasiv und
darum ist sie bereit dass mir die
jahrelang zu nehmen wenn sie muss
ausleben lang ob sie es immer so gut
vertragen wird wie jetzt ich habe nicht
sicher es gibt nämlich noch kein Studien
wo du wirklich von Maddy auf adipöse
Menschen länger als 2 Jahre untersucht
ja er holt sie Pause bis die nächste
Sekunde
natürlich cool
hast du eigentlich irgendwie mal
Probleme gehabt mit dem Gewicht nein
also
hat sie mich jetzt natürlich richtig
verwünscht ich bin privilegiert und bin
immer schlank sie der Druck von Jenny
als mir wichtige Frau ihrer Gesellschaft
erlaubt der kann ich nicht während eurem
Gespräch Leute der Arzt as Medi werde
knapp es Gabi Lieferung
aber sie hat Glück der Vorrat lange
nicht nur für Sie
eben mehr wegen diesen
Lieferschwierigkeiten da kriege ich ja
auch immer was zu hören bei tiktok dass
ich ja da den Diabetikern halt eben Ihr
Medikament wegnehmen aber eben es ist ja
ich bin da nicht der Meinung ich finde
ich habe da genauso Anspruch da drauf
ich will genau da bleiben wo ich bin ich
will genauso weitermachen ich will kein
anderes Medikament ich will keine
Experimente ich möchte doch keine
Nebenwirkungen der Medikament sind
großziehen ich frage beim Hersteller
nachher und der bestätigt mir dass es im
Herbst 22 und Anfang 320 Weg der Höhe
noch fragt lieferen happy Nova Nord ist
bittet mich übrigens auch zum nützt oder
nur sehr zurückhaltend über das
Medikament Berichte damit es nicht
wieder zum Rücken Knappheit Hund und
dass der Bestand für Diabetiker
sichergestellt ist ich finde aber
wichtig darüber sprechen
auf Social Media kursiert zu der Spritze
und will auch offen über negativ Folge
aufklären sind
Schuhe
Erfahrungen als Medikament noch mal
probieren sie hat mit ihrer Ärztin
abgemacht dass sie Dosis auf zweimal pro
Woche aufteilt will sie beim letzten Mal
die volle Ladung nicht gut vertreibt hat
fertig
so was hast denn jetzt nur für viel viel
weniger Appetit also ich bin ehrlich
jetzt ich kann
gar nicht
also ich hoffe klasse dass ich Hunger
okay
Ernährung und ich frage darum bin
Experten der Philipp Gerber der
klinische Leiter von der Endokrinologie
am adipositaszentrum in Zürich seit mir
das ist wie korrekte Dosierung
emotional Eater also Opa wo ist der
Gefühlslage ist ich denke jetzt nur so
ein Scheißtag
ich mir so richtig sagen Medikament ist
jedes Verhältnis zum Moment
aber will sie gar nicht so viel mag
Essen früher ist das anders gesehen
elena hat viel und schnell gassertacken
probiert hat hat Elena dann Spritzer vor
ihrer Ärztin fürs im Gegensatz zu der
Jenny übernimmt ihre krankenkassekosten
es geht ihrem Umfeld aber auch Personen
wo probiert illegaler das Medikaments
roh auch über sie sie bekommt von
Kolleginnen Nachrichten mit jedem
lassen
Bescheid tschüss er sich aber auch nicht
unbekannt das Lied das so bedient wo es
nicht über Kranke Kasse Beziehung
hast
dick oder sind wichtig
also wirklich normal wichtig so
Leute
Medikament
befasst haben wie man das dann überhaupt
aufnimmt und dann ist
schön für dich bist
wo ich regelmäßig übergeben
wirklich Sorgen machen
nicht unbedingt wenn du hast
Folge
vom Übergewicht auf der anderen Seite
und dann wieder so
weil es ist jetzt das kleinere Übel nach
dem Abschluss von der Dreharbeiten
schrieb mit Elena dass sie ihre Meinung
hat sie nimmt Medikamente
langzeitfolge sind für sie erst großes
Risiko sie möchte sich aktiv mit ihrem
Essverhalten und ihre Bewegungen
aber dann geht es darum zum die andere
Baustelle analogen was sind denn Problem
wo drunter liegt was möchte ich abpacken
und bin ich bereit zum das Medikament
wirklich auf lange lange
es zeigt mir aber auch wie groß der
Druck auf die Menschen nach wie vor
ihrer Gesellschaft ist hat er schon mal
vor der Spritze gehört oder der Hype auf
tiktok oder auf ein anderes Social Media
dann empfehle ich euch der Reporter